en Haití la frustración contra el
gobierno crece este lunes las protestas
dejaron un muerto en enfrentamientos con
la policía los manifestantes lanzaron
piedras en las autoridades que
respondieron con gases lacrimógenos
desde que el gobierno anunció la subida
del precio del combustible el 11 de
septiembre ahí sí se ha visto afectada
por manifestaciones y saqueos el
desempleo el alto costo de vida la
inseguridad es por todas estas razones
por las que estoy en la calle no a la
ocupación el gobierno ahí ya no pidió la
intervención de fuerzas internacionales
para hacer frente a la violencia y el
secretario general de la ONU Antonio
Gutiérrez llamó este domingo a
intervenir con rapidez pero la población
rechaza la posible intervención estoy en
la calle porque oigo que los blancos van
a pisotear el suelo del padre de salim
porque quieren pisotear a la lucha de
desalín como hicieron en 2004
la población denuncia la inacción del
gobierno respecto a la violencia entre
ondas criminales una situación que se
degradó en los últimos meses según
homenajes locales las mujeres sufren
particularmente de la crisis de
seguridad ya que su cuerpo está usado
como arma de guerra además el país sufre
un repunte en los casos de cólera más de
100 personas están siendo tratadas en
este Centro Médico de las Islas un
Barrio Pobre de la capital
el domingo pasado cuando me desperté vi
a mi hijo vomitando y con diarrea
[Música]
lo llevé a un centro cercano a mi casa
pero no había ningún médico que lo
atendiera
fue la gente de médicos Sin fronteras la
que nos llevó a este centro para que le
dieran los cuidados necesarios la
escasez de combustible y agua potable
así como la inseguridad dificultan aún
más el acceso a la asistencia sanitaria
en el país